welcome to you get cooking in cloud
where we share the best recipes to apply
in your cloud kitchen I'm Priyanka and
in this episode we are wrapping up the
mobile backend app recipe with Jen
[Music]
[Applause]
it's bittersweet that this is our last
mobile app back-end recipe I've had so
much fun cooking with you well it's been
great having you visit my kitchen so
tell me about this last recipe what are
we cooking up today today's solution
combines rest or G RPC with compute
engine ah so the ingredients then are
some sort of API with rest or G RPC and
compute engine exactly so I talked about
compute engine in the first season I'll
link the video below for any of our
viewers who didn't catch it well compute
engine lets you create and run virtual
machines on Google infrastructure you
have admin rights to the server and full
control over its configuration but this
also means that you are responsible for
updates and maintenance exactly Priyanka
compute engine gives you more
configuration control than my previous
recipes but that puts the onus on the
developer to monitor and maintain it now
there are two main protocols used to
connect to compute engine instances rest
and G RPC like all of my recipes the
choice you make here really depends on
your apps particular needs so I know
that rest is an architecture for network
app that uses HTTP request to post read
and delete data you can build REST API
on compute engine the App Engine
standard environment and the App Engine
flexible environment instances that your
app can call to access the backend
service you build in this case we're
specifying compute engine yes and G RPC
is a framework that makes it possible
for a mobile app to directly call
methods on a back-end service as if it
were a local object G RPC uses the HTTP
2 standard which introduces
bi-directional streaming flow control
header compression and the ability to
multiplex requests over a single TCP
connection you can use G RPC to make
your mobile app more bandwidth efficient
and to reduce latency between your app
and back-end service running on GCP you
can write G RPC clients and servers in
any of G RPC supported languages so you
could for instance create a G RPC server
Java with clients and go Python or Ruby
that is great overview of G RPC we also
talked about rest and compute engine so
far in which scenario would you
recommend this recipe I recommend
compute engine with rest or G RPC for
porting an existing back-end service
running on an on-premises server or a
virtual machine and back-end services
that require a custom server or third
party libraries so this could be good
solution for handling my legacy on Prem
code for Priyanka's kitchen exactly but
if your app requires automatic real-time
data synchronization across devices I
recommend using one of our firebase
solutions instead what if I prefer
automatic maintenance and scaling well
then this isn't the solution for you
since you must maintain and upgrade the
server yourself and you must manually
configure and manage and autoscaler
varakin developers learn more about
using compute engine with rest or G RPC
in their apps there is an end and sample
app called sticky notes that sends text
to the service which responds by
returning a generated image the sticky
notes sample is available in both rest
and gr PC versions so you can compare
the two protocols our agent that sounds
great I cannot wait to take a look at
the sticky notes sample app that's all
for today on get cooking in cloud with
this we have wrapped up the mobile app
back-end recipes on Google cloud if you
would like to know more about today's
recipe or any of the ones we have
covered in this season check out the
links in the description below if you
like this video then check out the other
episodes in the series and don't forget
to subscribe to our channel so you can
be notified about new episodes of get
cooking in cloud as well as other great
google cloud content
you